بعد ان طرد ماسك كبار المديرين التنفيذيين
وخفض اعداد الموظفين دون سابق انذار
اثريستيلائه اعلى منصه تويتر تحت شعار اذا
كنت لا تحب ماسك تعال واعمل معنا شركات
التقنيه تستقطب موظفي تويتر الذين غادروا
الموقع رساله الى كل من ترك تويتر نشرتها
احدى الشركات تطالبهم بالالتحاق بها ورغم
ان شركه التكنولوجيا الامريكيه الكبرى
الاخرى بما في ذلك ميتا وامازون قامت
بتسريح الاف الموظفين في الاسابيع الاخيره
بسبب البيئه الاقتصاديه لكن الانتقاد
العالم
الضوء على طلب القوي على العمال الرقمين
ذوي المهارات العاليه الذين شغلوا مناصب
حساسه في تويتر ولعل شركات التكنولوجيا
الامريكيه المنافسه تسعى للاستفاده من
خبرتها هؤلاء الموظفين والمهندسين خاصه
بعد نجاحات السنوات الماضيه التي حققها
طائره تويتر برفقتهم
ما في غضون ذلك تخبطات المنصه مستمره في
ظل قرارات المالك الجديده ايلون ماسك الذي
جعل العالم كله يهتم باخبر تويتر اكثر من
اي شيء اخر بلال العربيه